hi everybody good evening hopefully
everybody made here safely in the rain
we are really excited to have you all
here
my name is toga I am the CEO park and I
want to welcome you all to Park in part
four we have an amazing topic today that
hopefully is interest to everybody in
the room it's clearly an area and a
topic that's very close to my heart
mm-hmm and we're gonna talk about
artificial intelligence and the cutting
edge of AI and without further ado I
just want to introduce our moderator
Allen Tucker
thanks Olga hello everyone welcome how's
everyone doing good
all right good I'm glad that everyone
made it safe this is an excellent topic
we're really excited to share my name is
Alan Saki on I am a polymath I'm a host
and producer of a bunch of different
things including a science competition
feature festival and fireside chat
series where I ask really smart people
some of the world's will stop provoking
questions and AI is definitely in that
category so we're really excited can we
get a little bit of excitement from the
audience yeah awesome
awesome so I'll go ahead and introduce
everyone we'll just jump right off into
the questions so the first person that
you see on our panel is Piero Piero is a
cultural historian with a background in
artificial intelligence then next up on
our panel is Maya Maya focuses on
computational creativity really excited
for that and then we have Tolga who's
the CEO of park and he has a background
in AI as well and then lastly we have
Andra right here who is the managing
director of Silicon Valley robotics all
right
so I think that we all know that
everything is now being called ai ai
this AI that what's I guess what's the
difference when does an algorithm even
become AI and what are some very
relatable ways for us to understand the
way that we use AI in the daily lives I
guess I'm
skeptic here so in those in the audience
of know me they know that I don't like I
never liked the term artificial
intelligence and and today more than the
neighbor it said this really does never
been a definition you know I I wrote
down the definitions the McCarthy Minsky
gave you read them they don't say much
about when does a piece of software
become artificial intelligence so when
the AI is not popular
nothing is artificial intelligence when
they are is popular pretty much
everything that official intelligence I
spend half of my time in China where AI
is more popular than here and now I've
seen AI hotels there's an AI store at
the Shanghai Airport I mean very soon
the clock will be they are and so so
it's a it's actually a serious question
I mean when does a piece of software
become more than just a piece of
software right and yeah so I was asked
to teach artificial intelligence at
Santa Clara University where I'm a
professor so I had to go back and look
at what a AI is because of course I've
noticed that the definition is used very
loosely last year I remember somebody
came to visit my computational
creativity course to give an overview of
AI and they started back with Alan
Turing essentially defining computer
science which was very disorienting
because we want AI to be something
well-defined not just equivalent to
computer science broadly speaking it
originally included very heavily things
like logic the logic was considered part
of AI especially when it's applied to
computer science robotics have been part
of AI for a very long time there are
parts of AI that nobody knows about such
as game theory which has a very heavy
theory behind it more recently we hear
AI being equivalent to machine learning
and data science which it's not and that
can be a little bit frustrating because
machine learning especially deep
learning it's very popular it's a very
popular part of our
intelligence but it doesn't make it
artificial intelligence my favorite part
of AI is computational creativity which
is looking at making computers that are
creative in their own right or machine
collaborators at work with us on
creative tax tasks perhaps in a way
that's similar to how we might
collaborate with another human so there
are lots and lots of parts to AI and it
doesn't encompass all of computer
science and it's not just machine
learning yeah and it's also in a sense
an efficient shifting because McCarty
was right to complain when he works it's
no longer a lie like chess chess
programs like chess was one of the great
province of once it was solved now you
can buy chess programs of for a few
dollars in fact probably free online
nobody thinks that's AI anymore
because that's promise be solved but it
is technically because it's an expert
system an expert system they're part of
AI it's just not as hot exciting AI
anymore
so I guess people don't call it that as
often I mean that's actually the same
problem that we have with robotics where
once it starts working it's no longer a
robot it's so you know those robots
don't work in demos
as I believe some people found out at
CES this year that's well known but when
we started our association which was
started by robotics companies to support
robotics I had to very seriously try to
identify what we call robotics you know
it started with a certain group of
companies but companies change and the
makeup of the companies in our
association has gone through a lot of
change in you know eight to ten short
years and one of the reasons for that is
that there are now a lot of emerging
industries a lot of emerging startups in
the field of robotics because of the
advances in a whole range of physical
technologies and supporting software
technologies but to lead the definition
of robotics I would often look at who's
building it because if you tracked
through the career arc of certain people
who were very clearly robotics people
that work on quite a range of different
things so one woman who's very famous
whose name would come to me in a second
went from building surgical robots and
robot hands very sophisticated man to
working on the nest thermostat to
starting the Google X PRIZE also to
looking to be among the board at Twitter
another famous person who won the
autonomous vehicle first tab second
DARPA challenge then started working on
online multi-person courses they've
still got a background in robotics and
AI and those technologies clearly have
very wide application barriers but I'll
just take question one comment that you
made is that robotics and AI are really
close and have been for a long time
absolutely but robotics came first
get that straight you know so if we're
talking about the kind of creation story
about robotics and III it was in the
pursuit of the what was supposed to be
an easily solved problem let's just
build robots that can think and you know
no problem so we'll build AI to power to
be the brains of these robots that we
want to build and of course it turned
out that just building the AI was so
much more complicated and we could build
quite simple robot arms and they were
good for a lot of factory chores and
that's been the state of the industry
for 15 years meanwhile we started to put
computers into everything so AI has had
so many more opportunities to flourish
and here's the point right now this is
the tipping point because robotics
started AI at the moment a is on the top
and robotics is just starting to emerge
III is going to become dependent on
robotics again because you can't have AI
without all of the automation and
without the sensors to get your data and
what are the best you know I believe we
kind of saturated where computers
screens and where mobile phones go so
it's going to be our robots and our
robot products that are the next
generation of getting AI out into the
world
then what what's your what's your scope
of the definition for what do you think
about just robots isn't my fiction
movies robot is is your nest thermostat
example of a wireless thermostat is
because it's often connected with other
devices so if we go to the pure
definition of robotics which is a
machine that senses thinks and acts then
we've reached the stage where our
microwaves or robots our cars are
definitely
reading robots even if we do a lot of
the steering the car is doing a lot of
the other calculations and sensing so
the brakes get applied the way the car
thinks the brakes should be applied not
necessarily the way that we think these
are the gear changes and they're
incrementally increasing the amount of
autonomy that's given but I think you
have to look at it that way when we talk
about autonomous driving we think of the
car is the whole system whereas there's
a set of subsystems many of which are
actually autonomously sensing thinking
and acting already we have an industrial
definition of robotics which relates to
movement in three axis partial
programming and partial time now I think
movement in three axes is
stereotypically a robot arm but we have
a lot of autonomous vehicles that are
also robots by some definition the
Roomba robot is too stupid to really be
a robot but it's getting smarter and it
was marketed as a robot and it was built
by robot assists we just have an
increasingly sophisticated expectation
and I really believe that our next
episode robot is our house not the
anthropomorphic idea of a robot being
something like a person with the head
and the body arms and legs so let's take
that away that's the tip of the iceberg
the humanoid robot idea the rest is a
lot of smart devices that aren't always
objects they can be environments as well
I think that what you're bringing up
here is they're interesting this
tendency to imagine that anything
intelligent or creative or a robot has
to be humanoid and that the better it is
the more similar it is to us it's really
ultimately misleading because a lot of
work for example in computational
creativity that's very successful
doesn't try to imitate us neural
networks even perhaps the hardest part
of AI right now doesn't actually try to
imitate the way that human neural
networks work there was decades ago that
they realized that if they try to
imitate neural networks too closely to
how human brains work
doesn't actually lead to their good
results so AI in general and I guess
robots in particular do better when we
let them be a general let them develop
in a direction in which they're good
regardless of whether it happens to
align with our strengths or weaknesses
so I just want to say that we also have
had a good amount of time I guess what
they like you said with the start of
robotics that was hardware based and
then we transitioned to kind of more of
a software base right AI can be deployed
as software and within that then it gets
to live without Hardware necessarily and
then now it's kind of coming back to the
merger of needing a robot to in many
cases in some cases maybe you let's talk
a little bit about how AI learns how
does AI learn and then when does AI
become smarter than humans and is that
an existential problem I mean I think I
eyes has been smarter than humans in
many ways for a long time it beats cost
per of a chest decades ago and then we
quickly declared that that doesn't
matter the moment that right the moment
that computers can do something would
raise the bar whether its intelligence
or creativity or perhaps anything else
because fundamentally as humans we want
to be the best at ideally everything or
at least everything that matters yeah
and I think I think we almost need to
parse that question in because we talk
about AI as if it's one thing has been
applies to all the problems that we face
but but clearly that's that's not the
case the question is when does AI get
better for what category of problems
with what characteristics and when does
a I still chose quite significantly on
certain set of problems that humans are
much more superior so so I think if you
go one level down and start you know
kind of composing it into those
categories with problems in the
complexity and where I can help and
where I need you know
improvement is is important way to think
about it and even the whole idea of
intelligence there is still a lot of
debate as to what that actually measures
and it's certainly not the whole measure
of what it is to be human
by any means so when we're talking about
the equivalences we're taking a very
kind of narrower slice and trying to fit
that and I like your suggestion that
it's a little bit competitive too
because we want to win whatever that is
so I agree that your question needs to
be passed because there's really two
things there one you said something
about learning just a lot at word and
the second one you said Santa bomber
scene being better than us I think most
machines if not all of them are built
exist because they do something better
than the average person
the clock is my favorite example there's
no human being no matter how smart they
can tell this how many minutes in
seconds we'll be speaking but that
machines can do it it was invented
thousand years ago so most machines do
something better than humans can do what
when we win we can do all those things
ok we will not beat out for God but
alphago is an incredibly stupid machine
it can do only one thing we don't have a
name for a human being can do only one
thing and keeps doing it non-stop
alphago right now is playing against
itself right don't stop non-stop
non-stop non-stop
well we watch TV we take a walk we do
many things we can cross the street
we're going to useful things we can also
invent machines by God but in terms of a
machine by something better than us I
think that addresses all the time can
you run as fast as your car
but on the other hand machines are ours
we make them right so in some sense I
mean in a very real way the whole
advantage of being human is that we can
make tools and suddenly we are creating
tools that are so amazing that we are
intimidated by them and we are scared of
them which is a little bit amusing
actually because they're here to help us
but the second part the learning part
that's the real question
well we can discuss how it's how
dishwasher does a dishwasher learn to do
what it does not really it's been it's
been you know there's a hardware thing
there that makes you do when can you say
the machine actually learned to do
something so that's that's I think more
complicated question to ask well we can
we can try to address that if you guys
want yeah so older AI used to be more
like the washing machine that you just
mentioned it was more about taking a
process that we understand and putting
it into a machine so that it could do it
so to give you a fun example
Harold Cohen who was fortunately versed
in the Castaway had a system named Aaron
that could paint he was a painter and
he's he created an automated artist that
autonomously created paintings really
beautiful pieces of art so the ones with
decades ago yeah this is before machine
learning before don't think this only
happened when Google started doing
talking about that's right so this is
surprisingly little-known this is back
when before Photoshop before it was easy
to visualize things in a computer screen
Harold Coyne had this massive set up
with robot arms that had paints in there
that would move around and it is really
sophisticated system just so you could
put paint on paper to create this
artwork but these were expert systems I
think that they're fascinating and I
think in a way it doesn't matter if it's
an expert system
if it's doing something amazing but we
move past it right now I have a computer
system
it's called Alisha that I created
precisely because I didn't know how to
do something so I in the middle of my
PhD I started learning how to sing opera
because apparently doing a PhD in
computer science was not enough to do so
I learned how to sing and became
something professional at some point I
decided I was taking a bus I remember
this really vividly I decided that I
want to write original songs and you
know I suppose cocky as I was you know
doing my PhD and learning how to sing
opera I thought that I could write
original songs no problem let me just
sit down and try to do it and for three
years
I couldn't figure out how to write a
good melody I could write melodies but
they were so bad I could not imagine
spending time producing them spending
time learning to perform them because
they were horrible and it was when I was
introduced to computational creativity
that I decided to create a collaborator
for myself that could help me come up
with original melodies so I wanted to
give it lyrics and have it come up with
original melodies for them now it's very
important that unlike Harold Coyne and
David cope actually who said I could
talk about it lang says well he created
these amazing pieces of music but again
because he was a composer and he could
put the rules into the computer I
couldn't do it I wanted the machine to
do something that I didn't know how to
do and we did within three months we had
a prototype and if you want to play with
it try Elysia calm you can compose with
a system that was written by you know
largely by a person who cannot compose I
had a workshop where people were
creating music with Alicia and one of
the students was insistent that she was
collaborating with me she wasn't
collaborating with my system Alicia
which is absurd because she could not
collaborate on composition with me cuz I
don't know how to compose right so we're
really moving forward very briefly the
way that AI works just in a few
sentences is it tries to predict so the
most prototypical example is predicting
whether a certain stock is going to go
up or down so you look at a lot of
historical
and you try to make educated guesses
most simply you know binary yes or no is
it gonna go up or down now when you look
at generative systems like Elysium
we have to somehow take that something
that can predict it's good at saying yes
or no for a specific point into
something that can generate so what you
do is these AI generative systems is you
try to predict what the next node is
going to be so you ask Alesia in my case
what is the next node and it's going to
take a guess and you simply agree with
it then you ask it again what is the
next node and you agree with it again
with a certain confidence you can
predict it that's right but it's not
it's actually really interesting that in
generative systems the confidence
doesn't become as important as it is in
something like predicting stock value
going up or down because there's a
subjective nature of music makes it so
that a system that's actually very good
at predicting the next note might not be
the one that you want to use to generate
right so it's a more it's a lesser known
and more more new part of artificial
intelligence where we have to deviate
from some of the established standards
in deep learning and we need that so
much because you know if you think about
it we're using AI to solve some of the
world's largest problems based on
historical data that we socially have
agreed is describing conditions that we
want to change and improve on I can
speak of things like gender equity for
example so this is one of the biggest
ethical issues that we run into if we're
building systems that are based on that
a data-driven and a predicting based on
that we run into problems that are
difficult to fix and yet I don't see
that we're using generative AI in any
widespread fashion yet I heard of
something related to this I believe it
was either credit score's and it was
credit scores that once somebody looked
into the AI system behind this credit
score system
they realized that it was biasing
against certain nationalities because if
you don't if we're not careful if we're
not directing the way they eyes
used it could actually end up supporting
some of the negative trends in our
society yep
maybe before we get there I want to ask
about that but Olga I want maybe to hear
you're gonna teach some of the audience
about what you guys are doing at Park at
this you know high level research and
development in AI yeah I think I now
being as prominent as it is is fairly
horizontal so it touches on a lot of the
things that we do one way or another but
I want to separate this there's
applications of AI to various different
problems and technologies a moment and
then there's really thinking about AI in
AI signs and taking that to the next
level as well in that in that context I
want to talk to maybe maybe mention a
few areas that what kind of exploring
you know the the frontiers of science if
you will one is in bringing transparency
which we deemed to be an extremely
critical problem for further adoption of
artificial intelligence and that you
know roughly speaking all these AI
systems are black boxes and they operate
in a blackbox fashion you see a bunch of
data and then they learn what they learn
including the biases that's in the data
and then they make prediction right and
when you ask why they why they come up
with a certain set of recommendations
they can't help you and that poses a
problem that poses a problem in many
different dimensions but primarily it
poses a problem from from establishing
the right level of trust between a human
agent and an AI agent so that they can
actually work very collaboratively with
one another in solve its problems
whether that's composing music painting
right so so we have a set of we have a
set of research activities that we
really looks at that transparency
problem in AI and then the next step of
that naturally is you know as you bring
transparency into AI and eliminate that
black box nature and build the trust it
opens a new frontier in terms of how to
think about the science of human-machine
collaboration so it's not about pushing
the pushing the limits of automation
and they're pushing the limits of
learning to push the AI to the to the to
the next levels but it's about thinking
about what we're good at which is what I
was trying to allude to earlier as
humans and what AI is good at is
algorithms and how to bring those two
together is symbiotic teams so that they
can tackle a very different set of
problems that are that are higher degree
that have higher degree of complexity
and then we work on intelligent
assistance is another area the basically
more more with the with an antic price
flavor
obviously this were part of Xerox
Corporation we do quite a bit of work
for them we think about enterprise
business business workflows and how can
knowledge worker what workers become
more productive in getting their jobs
done and how to bring in in that same
realm of you know human machine
collaboration how can we bring some
intelligent assistance into that
employment context so that they can they
can get their jobs done much much better
and then the last one I want to mention
and which touches upon the robots idea I
think we don't call them robots with
co-op systems but this whole notion of
machine intelligence how do you how do
you enable machine systems robots
whatever you want to call them to be
better at sensing thinking and acting
and and and there's a number of mega
trends in technology which is you know
sensing becoming ubiquitous and low-cost
and highly customized and a lot of
real-time data that is being generated
everywhere from from the nests and
drones and cars and other kinds of
devices how do you think about all of
that and had a couple that with the with
the new and and state-of-the-art AI in
learning algorithms so that you can
actually enable those machines to be to
be better and sentencing thinking
enacted can you bring up how half of the
conversation is about humans maximizing
what we're really good at and then
robots and AI maximizing algorithms what
they can do repetitively that maybe we
don't want to do yeah what what has been
kind of the answer for yeah I think I
think I think we were sort of in the
early stages of really having that
answer but but I think I think it it's a
little bit maybe it's nuanced but it's
an important one is it's not so much I
have a problem and let's break this down
into pieces where a human can solve some
sub parts and then in a machine can
solve some other parts of it it's really
thinking about it whole holistically and
how that's why the word collaboration is
really important because we're not
thinking about break down and assign one
versus other it's about how do I compose
with the system together if not I give
it a task it gives me an answer back
but can it help can we build off of each
other can can I you know we talked about
you know how do they learn learning also
implies teaching but but it's a two-way
street in our view that we think that as
humans we can teach AI agents and AI
agents can teach us and we're also
exploring that that interplay between
teaching and learning it release these
systems in this context of communication
abilities it's actually really
interesting I'm really fascinated how
much your experience in a completely
different field aligns so perfectly with
because what I see in computational
creativity so one of the things I think
I could give a pretty good concrete
example here one of the things that
machines are very good at is exploring
the space of possibilities one of the
things that humans are very good at is
being able to tell when you notice
something good so in case of elysia
which is you know my focus
machines at least you know if you crazy
them well are very good at coming up
with many different options for you so
they can create little pieces of art or
they can create the little melodies and
then a human even a known artist can
come back and tell whether they like the
melodies or like the pieces of art and
choose amongst them so that's how that's
one way that you can task divided have
the machines that are generate and have
the human evaluate yeah so this seems to
be a field that I don't think many of us
understand well we've been near just
sort of starting to get into our Mayas
how can robots or artificial
intelligence be creative it seems to be
almost you know we've just barely
developed into creativity just recently
in the evolutionary spectrum how are we
gonna teach robots in AI to potentially
be creative yeah well it kind of goes
back to what the era was saying in a way
we first need to break down what it is
that we're talking about before we can
decide whether a machine can do it so
when I teach computational creativity we
always start with what is human
creativity and it becomes very quickly
very obvious that we can't grasp really
what creativity is in us and then what
happens is that the moment that a
computer does something that would be
considered creative for a human who very
quickly redefined what creativity is to
make sure that computers don't taken
away from computers have done a lot of
things that would be considered creative
for a person they can paint their work
has been exhibited in galleries one of
the most famous systems right now is a
painting pool whose goal is not to
create art alone but to actually be
recognized as a legitimate artist so
it's work for example has been
commissioned for some very impressive
sums of money its work is regularly
exhibited in galleries and that's an
autonomous artists it's not a
co-creative system and we have analogous
systems to those in music which are
often co-creative as well
we have some of my colleagues work on
java improvisation so there is this
amazing video of a human pianist
collaborating with an autonomous piano
and they together create these beautiful
pieces of music so I think in a very
real sense computers are already
creative but of course we're moving the
bar so right now perhaps similar to
transparency we want we expect computer
artists or we want them to be able to
explain what is the meaning behind their
artwork so that's one one direction and
I really think that we're gonna make
progress and of course somebody's gonna
come around and say that's not enough
and that's gonna give us a new challenge
and that's how the field moves forward
but definitely things are right now a
lot further than I think most people are
aware it's really interesting so I'm
gonna build on something you mentioned
so part of the transparency in mostly in
the context that we worked about is is
about explain ability and it's really
interesting concept as well I think EU
is actually on its way to actually make
it with a requirement for these
algorithms to be able to articulate and
explain themselves and and and and so
that's really interesting if you combine
what we what you said I think creative
it is really interesting example because
you cannot actually codify how it
happens but you can look at the output
and then you can make a judgment about
whether that was a creative and output
of a creative a process or not in the
same way if you think about you know if
you've combined that with with
explainable it's really interesting then
you can actually if you achieve that
level of explained ability maybe it can
actually help us get to the explanation
of what created it might mean by means
of doing that so I'm also interested in
that scientific kind of creativity been
interested in how we come up with
scientific theories the paradigm shifts
you know somebody comes up with the idea
that gravitation that the Apple falling
from the tree and the planets turning
around the Sun are the same thing or
Isis relativity so a little bit of
history one of the very early a I
progress with the GPS general problem
solver done by Simon and no oil I think
1957 and at that time it was they
thought IntelliJ
is mathematical logic you know if you
can solve a theorem mathematical logic
you have human intelligence turned out
there was the easy part of they are and
they quickly quickly realize this and in
fact I think in 1863 Simon himself at
one of his students are in business his
name work on analogical reason
trying to come up with a creative idea
based on something that you know and at
CMU does at the time was called called
Carnegie in Co technology Walter right
man objected what you are doing basic
mathematical logic is not what we do the
human mind is chaotic the human mind
continuously creates generates ideas and
then eventually one seems to fit in you
go after that why that one what
sometimes just aesthetics it just looks
beautiful
sometimes it just fits the so that was
the beginning of a branch of artificial
intelligence now everybody talks about
the success stories of AI we have to
write the book about the failures which
I call theory information how can you
have a machine come up with a theory ok
I give you some data now don't just give
me the pattern come up with that with
that with that with a formula like a new
toss form ok so that has been going on
for a long time 1963 that's why I was
mentioning the date now it's 50
something years later that's an
extremely complicated problem actually
turns out you know how the human mind
suddenly changes the view of the world
and comes up with idea you know what
space-time is warped you know things
like this there is some work happening
at Georgia Tech where they they're
trying to intentionally mix different
fields to try to make these discoveries
automatically so some of the greatest
discoveries happened by looking at work
in biology the particularly
understanding how different Mirena
work and then we can take that back into
technology and build in analogous
systems and they've been there is an
effort if there is degrees of research
to try to to make this happen
intentionally I've said what's called
conceptual blending so what one of the
it's well known that one of the best
ways that creative ideas come about is
by taking existing things and blending
them and they're trying to do that
toward scientific discovered discovery
in an automated way and today that one
field is very interesting in this is a
biotech is another quality healthcare
industry whatever
why because designing drugs and
developing them is a long process it's a
stream expensive you have to do so many
trials and then each one cost a lot of
money if you succeed besides making a
lot of money you save lives okay so so
we started realizing we don't have
enough drugs for people even if we have
so much you know so many data we can't
come up with the drugs just because it's
so complicated to come up with theories
of how proteins work out genes work and
so on
so now AI applied scientific theory as a
very practical application so area is
now permitting it's almost every single
industry it's assisting people it's
reducing suffering providing food
providing healthcare so many different
things well what about the other side of
AI the side of AI that we can
potentially unleash into a market to
maximize our money who is going to be
programming ethics into AI
in the last couple of years there have
been so many new groups forming to
discuss the ethics of AI and autonomous
systems that it's clearly the time for
it to be on everybody's agenda all the
way up to the World Economic Forum one
of the things that fascinates me is I'm
in the middle of the processing robotics
where the Pioneers tended to have
ethically well designed systems because
they had spent their whole lives
building things but what I see is as the
first wave moves through and the next
generation and multiplies it does it
much more with much less I guess
training and thought so I think we start
to get a lot of careless thoughtless
products in the world and I think that
this is a tipping point that we've
reached algorithmically where things
that seemed like a good idea at the time
start to seem not so great in practice
you know bye-bye democracy for example
but the questions that have been have
you say the answers that pretty much
come up even though in some cases the
principles are 27 or 35 or 137 or in
some only three or four Center around
the idea of transparency and
accountability because we can't even
assign liability and responsibility if
we can't explain exactly what just
happened please elaborate on bye-bye
democracy
I remember the days when we thought the
internet was going to be untrammeled
goodness open and support something like
democracy which was the ability of
everybody to have their voice heard one
of the reasons I became very interested
in ethics and design of technologies
broadly is I'm also old enough to have
been knocked back for astronaut training
when I sent my ten-year-old letter off
to NASA because I was a girl and to have
been heard from those were in my life
growing up in my father's physics lab
with my mother programming the
university's mainframe computer that's
unusual for a girl at a certain point in
time I started to find that what was
most fascinating wasn't building the
rockets and the robots that was asking
why doing that was unusual for a girl
and how we were coding and encoding all
of our social formation into our
technologies and then what the impact
with those included technologies was
going to have a feedback on to our
society and to see if we could start to
work out where these patterns were
developing and kind of head them off at
the pass as it were I'm old enough to
have seen the development of the first
pages on the internet I could predict
that that was going to be a rather macho
trollish environment and I stopped
mucking around on the computers I went
back to so narrow but it's an AI because
clearly letting things go doesn't help
us we've got to be right in the center
of what is happening to
understand what the promise and the
peril to use a Victorian phrase and I
think it's very difficult for a start-up
to do something it's much easier for a
large company to do something it's
possible for us to create regulations
potentially even at global levels we're
not necessarily always to implement them
but what are the things is as a society
we have even if they're imperfect many
social frameworks already what we need
to do is harness the parts where we use
those things and pay a lot of attention
I think I'm a big fan of continents fast
thinking slow thinking one of the things
that's happening right now with our
technology is that it's using a lot of
our fast thinking systems rather than
our slow thinking systems and our
economy is biased towards that kind of
endorphin like responsiveness yes you
know even if we look at things like
companies reporting to shareholders or
quarterly basis how can a company then
develop technologies that it would
further the world over a 50-year period
so all of our problems with AI and
robotics ultimately they come back to as
Norbert Weiner said people problems and
I loved that he wrote back in 63 or 64
that the future isn't a comfortable
hammock that we can lie back in and be
waited upon by our robot slaves it's an
ever more demanding struggle against the
limitations of human intelligence really
well fit also is there other thoughts
from you guys about AI ethics maybe
about artificial general intelligence
posing an existential threat I think
that's a really important topic I think
the human race is so lucky to even have
flourished on this rock orbiting the
star in the first place we only got here
because the asteroid Inc
killed the dinosaurs it's like this
there's so many filters that are going
to just eradicate us from this planet
just like you know five stars down and
aligned already it happened to AI seems
like the next filter you so how do we
get past that filter yeah I might have
sounded a little bit on the negative
side but I'm also techno optimistic
because I just want to add think of the
pace of expansion of human knowledge
we're only a few hundred years ago all
of human encoded knowledge could be
captured in one library when people
could talk about it could really explore
every subject and now I calculated how
many years it took me to read all of the
books in the University of Sydney
library when I went back to study and I
realized that I wasn't even going to be
able to keep up in my discipline which
is a splinter of a fraction of what the
that single University encompasses and
how many universities do we have and how
many and you realize how essentially
things like this and search become so
we've become already augmented
completely but it is the way that we are
now solving problems so our definition
of human has changed we are all cyborgs
right now so let's enjoy that - I think
really worrying about artificial general
intelligence is premature
to say the least garry kasparov
I think it was him that the world chess
champion said before we start worrying
about what machines do we should worry
about what machines still cannot do
because they could do a lot more for the
human race not doing and the other thing
that's there's a lot of talk against
Silicon Valley right now it is view it
let's talk automation not artificial
intelligences as as we say the beginning
is difficult to define there's a lot of
talk that what Silicon Valley is
producing somehow is going to be
and they sustained shot thread for the
human race
it's while you exaggerated and we risk
missing the point that humans are still
the number one existential threat so I
think if you want if you want to find an
enemy of the human race don't look at
Silicon Valley look at Washington DC yet
you know what these days that's the
number one killer of people is people
literally whether it's by murdering
suicide that might change though very
soon it's already happening with
autonomous drones that the the rationale
behind the military use of drones and
they've written a huge paper on the
ethics of autonomous warfare if anybody
is seriously interested in that subject
is because it saves more American lives
so you know I try to avoid the ethics of
warfare because it's tautology but we
have evolved a set of rules and robots
are far from the first existential
technological threat when we faced
chemical warfare a nuclear warfare this
thing this thing is truly dangerous it's
collecting a lot of data about us all
the time all the time all the time and I
would worry about this before I worry
about and then all you need is an AI to
parse that data about you and then it
can make some prediction about your life
that you don't even know and then use
that as blackmail against you have so
many on the on the cloud that there are
hundreds or invisible robots that are
looking at these data right now yeah
what can we find in Piero's library of
photos
let's look just as a joke or friends
either there is a hypothesis that I
heard recently that humans of the near
future are gonna become very comfortable
with being constantly watched and
listened to and I'm gonna become just
less sensitive to privacy I'm not sure
that they already are constantly
listened to you have Google home or
Amazon alike
we have the Maps Google Maps it's
constantly pulling daddy or you know all
the tags on your emails so all right
let's let's talk about human capital
changing and I think there's so many
people in this room that have work that
some people like their work some people
don't like their work we see millions of
jobs being automated across many
different industries from transit to
just the service industry retail
industry what's the essence of how human
capital is going to change the next 10
years and what kind of work will we be
doing and what should we teach our kids
so I'd like to comment on I think it
ties back to what Aundre was saying
earlier I think this is more of a social
issue than it is a purely technological
issue
I really doubt primarily because of the
things that were pointed out earlier
companies are under such enormous
pressure to make profit that it's highly
unlikely they're gonna both create the
tech and find the social solutions for
us it is perhaps not entirely their
place to organize our society I don't
think we even want them to so as a
society we need to take responsibility
and figure out what kind of world we
want to live in as AI gets more and more
sophisticated the fear unfortunately is
that we're gonna see the same phenomena
that we see far too often where with any
human advancement the rich get richer
leaving more and more segments of
society behind for example with
autonomous driving which I think
fundamentally is such an amazing thing
and it's gonna save many lives truck
driving is one of the most popular jobs
out there and what's going to happen to
all of these truck drivers
I belittle step in there this is my hope
because it and also on the point before
privacy is an incredibly recent concept
that has only ever been possible for the
wealthy in the last hundred years or
perhaps the middle class shall we say
everybody before that either lived in
groups or was surrounded by people so
the fact that we worry about privacy now
is actually less in this is a very
recent construction we say but going to
the the next issue is truck drivers
which if you look not at the job stats
for how many people have the job look at
the figures for how many job vacancies
there are and you will find that vacant
truck driving positions are more than
vacant manufacturing positions and there
are a lot of vacant manufacturing
positions so when you really dive into
it the areas that are being let's say
automated by machinery because I think
we've just seen a huge takeover of a lot
of kind of white-collar jobs through
automation through computerization we
worry a lot more about robots and yet
that's going to be a slower change the
physical infrastructures are a little
bit harder to change but the jobs the
incentive to put robots into jobs is
because people are not doing those jobs
because human labor is cheap and I can
tell you I listen to a lot of startup
pictures I've been involved in a lot of
investment groups and mentoring and if
you take a pitch to any investor and you
say I'm going to replace a human they'll
go we'll come back with the scheme
that's going to make money you know not
only that but human
is infinitely replaceable in many ways
okay
terminally just as opposed to migrate
quite a large cost in terms of it's
probably third about of total cost I
mean you can look at Park if you look at
your balance sheets view look get
Starbucks if you look at truck drivers
there are third of the cost of the
company okay I do think we've got to
worry about the inequalities in wealth
separation because if you dig deeper
into the truck driver story as well it's
the same stories with taxi drivers ten
percent of truck drivers and taxi
drivers partly owned their own business
they suffer much more when sup that it's
an automated process or uber comes in
then the person who's working for part
of the fleet so it really comes down to
the ability for our less well-off
classes to have social mobility I think
that's not talked about a lot yes and
that's where if we can utilize robotics
in the way if we consider it like power
tools for this next generation and yet
try and facilitate small businesses
around or artisanal businesses it sounds
a little bit strange to talk about
automation and artisans yet that's
actually what can make cost-effective
production in small batches in local
areas possible when you try and take the
truck driver or somebody that is a
barista at Starbucks that knows a
repetitive process and you try and teach
them how to become an artisan you try
and teach them how to do a creative
problem-solving process that is not a
six-month retraining process go to every
Starbucks barista there's the ones that
don't talk and then there's the ones
that talk and often see themselves as a
creative artist and that the
communication is
that you will not get when you automate
that process but I'm not saying that the
jobs are safe because again human labor
is the cheap part of the equation what
Starbucks spend the most money on is the
real estate so there is actually a trend
right now and it happened before robots
so this is where Chipotle is taking a
large share of the retail takeout food
business because the footprint when you
serve up food in that fashion is smaller
than when you're doing a lot of the more
traditional fast-food type industry so
we're seeing a general information and
the cost-saving comes from machines that
can make processes possible in smaller
footprints and we've seen this with
banks with the spread of ATMs and
everybody said they're taking away two
bank teller jobs but there was actually
a net gain because banks were able to
create many more branches offering the
same services but with fewer people so
they open more branches and employed
more people one of the other equations
around robots and labor sorry to belabor
the point is that in most studies of
factories primarily around automotive
and consumer electronics because that's
where the most industrialization has
happened the factories that used robots
lost some jobs but became more
productive more successful and employed
more people where you are in danger of
losing your job is actually in the
factory that didn't automate because it
went broke and closed down or sent the
jobs to another country
I think I think that mr. automation
taught this lesson for centuries it's of
course I understand the concern at
suriak Oh sir
the experiment with trucks has been done
in in many Asian countries they use
trains you know United States is being
left behind in this sense and so a lot
of truck drivers in China today don't
drive trucks yes hopefully they do
something else China is a communist
country by the way so I think there's a
problem with automation in general right
you look at the movies from the 30s and
the 40s you see these huge rooms full of
people typically women typing or
something called typewriters the younger
people here never seen a typewriter so
it's always been that case now in the
case of automation that we have today it
gets a little more difficult to retrain
people that we have to admit that it is
more complicated China in fact which
long story but last year a I became an
official national Chinese program a
sanctioned by the president in science
technology this is not something I read
in the news my wife Jing Jie is from
China she's she's working on some of
these programs in primary school in
primary school so of course there is an
issue there but the issue is not new
technology has always done that it has
always displaced workers and and the
biggest tragedy is always people my age
because if you are 25 26 you can still
adapt quickly to the new technology if
you spend your life working in trucks or
whatever else and suddenly you have to
change job because your job is dying or
your salary is going down yes I
understand the concern
one more thing I'm not an economist but
simple statistic the the European
country with the highest density of
robots is Germany
the Asian country with the highest
density of robots is Japan and the
American country with the highest
density robots the United States now
take a while guessed which are the
countries with the lowest unemployment
in each continent Germany Japan USA now
it doesn't mean that everything's good
there's a lot of people whose salary has
declined increments decline so just be
employed doesn't mean anything but it's
not true that just automation destroys
jobs it also creates jobs self now the
question is are they better or worse
than what you had and so on so yeah I
think I think there's a look there is a
local scale and a more global scale of
that right so so there are clearly this
set of set of tasks and jobs that that
are likely to be eliminated due to
automation and they I in Michigan or
whatnot and then there's some others
that are safer perhaps and then the
local effect is those people that
actually get you know they feel the pain
if you will that that that work in those
tasks but I want to kind of push back a
little bit on something is happier is is
the you know age demographic is one
thing in that and I agree with what you
said but I think one thing that were
overlooking now with with actually
amplifies the problem that we're facing
is the pace of Technology yes
the technology has challenged us and
automation has challenged us to kind of
rethink about all of this and rescale
ourselves in a way that then you know it
created some jobs but we were able to
kind of catch up and and and reallocate
where we deploy our skills as human
client but that was done before and I
think the the stark contrast from the
history from the past and now is we're
living in a world that where there is
not a single technological wave that's
coming we talk about AI here but talk
about AI and they'll talk about IOT talk
about blockchain and you put all those
together it's it's changing so fast that
those that are left behind and that gets
displaced all of the workforce degrees
killing and Retraining challenges that
unprecedented levels because of that
pace of Technology and that's what we
need to think I'd really like to comment
on that it kind of I know I brought up
the truck drivers and thank you for
qualifying that you know the positive
aspects as well but I'm an educator and
I've worked to public universities in
the United States and our education
he's already terribly underfunded there
are people who want to go to university
and can't there are people who there are
so many issues whereas in Canada I had
four-year training in computer science
there are universities here where the
computer science training is essentially
two years which is not enough it's not
and I watch over and over again students
losing jobs to people who come from
other countries which of course in a way
is great but we should first be
educating our own people in AI is of
course contributing to this issue both
in positive and negative ways but
ultimately it's a social issue and we
need to be putting funds towards
educating our own people and I think
without that we are gonna see people who
kind of fall out of this system very
well say all right shall we go ahead and
open up for some questions from the
audience we have a hand up right there
maybe let's keep a round of applause for
our panel
[Applause]
great job everyone I think we covered a
lot of great topics yes thank you very
much my favorite robot-assisted is
Ridley Scott and what's kind of
interesting is is that from the
perspective of the early 70s the visions
presented in Terminator and more
importantly in my view in Blade Runner
are really about in smart machines
autonomous machines and then biological
computers if you will and what what is
the ethics of biological computers in
the sense of Nexus 6 this was the year
that of the incept dates of the Nexus
replicants and Skynet
I believe when intelligent developed
consciousness in 2019 if I'm not
mistaken has read Isaac Asimov's 15 year
predictions that he wrote for the 1964
World Fair it was pretty good yeah I
would invest in his stock but it's not
that it's not that the predictions
failed all all these predictions fail in
a 30 year perspective but but the one
the question I have is given that his
background is we've moved as your
t-shirt clearly shows for mechanical
computers and
cart programming to electronics where
where is intelligence in biology in
wetware if you will and and how how will
that affect the kinds of capabilities
the speed and the ethical concerns that
you have I I think there is so many
areas of interest that you've raised and
I think we're just putting the
foundational stones together to start
merging some of these areas so a number
of my friends do swarm robotics and they
tend to be more in the medical and
mathematical fields and yet that's being
applied in robots it's also being
applied in cells and biomimicry plays a
really strong part in the development of
robotic systems and then the development
of robotic systems feeds back and play
pays actually quite a lot it feeds back
into our research on how physical
systems or biological systems work and
operate so there is cross-pollination
and it needs to continue and in fact one
of my kind of pieces is that in some
fashions
we've gender coded electronics as male
and organics as female and one of the
things that I notice is I don't push so
hard to get women into robotics and
electronics I try to get them more into
modeling mathematics and biochemistry
because I see that as perhaps being the
next thing if we're looking into you
know training and future proofing
let's not necessarily teach out we know
any more but that's a kind of big theory
also in terms of the films you raised
you probably will enjoy ex machina okay
a really great musing on the whole thing
of human but you also raise a really big
point there is that we always conflate
artificial intelligence with agency okay
so the question should be not what can
computers were artificial until
just do or what can't it do that what on
earth wouldn't want to do and I don't
believe that currently our systems have
anything near a biological imperative
who's next
you're in charge of them hi everyone my
name is Omar also with Omar we came from
Dubai I'd also like to announce that we
also have now the first minister of
artificial intelligence
his name is also Omar so we don't have
one yet we need one we need a minister
of artificial goddesses yeah that's
exactly the reason why we want to try to
be number one in in establishing AI
across all government services to people
so excellent discussion I'm also a
writer so I'm writing my second book and
this is the reason why Omar and I we
came here because we want to collect a
lot of this content for the book which
is about AI and everything else as you
mentioned my question sir was regarding
alpha zero you said that it was
technically you know stupid it could
only do one thing maybe just play chess
or play up in alphago but then think of
Google itself like right now we feed it
so much information about so many
different topics isn't it becoming super
intelligence and only God knows what's
in the moonshot lab that they talk about
it says it's completely confidential but
do you not think that the machine will
probably do a lot of different things
that we're constantly feeding it
information every single day on
different topics just asking that's
actually a very complicated question
because it sounds like a simple question
but it really goes back to the finish of
intelligence what is intelligence see in
the seventies eighties were building
expert systems the idea was we build a
machine that will give answers to
complicated questions like medicine okay
I have this these symptoms tell me what
what what I should do now what what do I
haven't saw that program failed one of
the many failures never failed for many
reasons but one reason is very simple
you google it you'll need to have all
these intelligence in a machine to give
the answer you just Google and you find
somebody posted here well unfortunately
people now you now you find too much
yeah okay so so if you look at the whole
universe the Google search engine is
searching is that an intelligent system
that goes back to definition
intelligence if to you intelligence is
just something that does where the human
does yeah then the whole web is
intelligent but of course if you think
in terms is it conscious then probably
it's not conscious so so the the
question is actually very complicated
because first you should live dude we
would have to define intelligence and
nobody is that definition I would I
would answer your question by saying
that yes it is absolutely insanely
important for us to better understand
what actually is going into that system
every single day millions and millions
of different searches and enquiries for
different people that they can log and
pin that this person's asking about this
medical condition and this person is
traveling to China this many times all
the sort of information what is actually
being done with it how can we maximize
human potential with it not destroy
people with it all the important stuff
[Music]
it absolutely can especially if it's
running on an open platform it did
absolutely Ken if your objective is to
maximize funds which for so many people
on the planet is their objective and you
let it loose cannon out onto the
financial markets or whatever system you
want there is a major problem with
something like that okay I feel I need
to organize this a little bit we can't
we can't go around saying that just
because Google has a lot of information
that it can search that makes it
incredibly intelligent okay granted it's
an incredible accomplishment in its own
right because we all know that they had
this super sophisticated algorithm for
search and then eventually I'm not sure
exactly what they're doing now but at a
certain point the best search results
were the search results that people who
typed exactly the same query found
useful okay so having a lot of data is
helpful of course of course is an
incredible accomplishment to have
everything together on you you've logged
in with your gmail account and you
search and you have a calendar and you
have Google Maps and you have yeah
that's not amazing to me it just could
just collecting information right we can
make lots of great things in searching
and apply some machine learning so they
can personalize the results to me okay
still that doesn't make it a system that
has different forms of intelligence it
just has lots of data okay it still does
it's still task-specific all AI right
now is task specific we don't have
anything remotely resemble in general
intelligence
okay so just I wanted to separate having
information on different different
topics versus having different kinds of
cognitive abilities that are coming
together I hope that was helpful
I guess back there and then let's take
this middle you've cut you've had your
book up the honey eat now let's go to
your next okay so yeah if you look at
the evolution of Technology you know if
somebody holding a sword and in the in
the 1600s would be the equivalent of
owning a Ferrari today right it was very
it was beyond your reach right and look
at how someone had a computer that if
you walk there on with a book that was
something that was really
technologically advanced to now just
having a paper book it kind of kind of
goes from someone who has a lot of money
to own down to something that's just
very ubiquitous there's writing on
everything whereas before if you could
write that was unbelievable so if you
take AI right now if you take AI and
just say a drone or something that looks
like a dog from from Boston robotics and
it's very expensive where do you where
does this panel see in the next few
years what happens when it's ubiquitous
down to the point where everyone can own
it the average person can own it where
do you where does a panel see that going
what do you think that world look like I
think one of the things that we have to
watch is that right now our world's
organization and the the leading
organized state organizers of
information are making their money on
advertising we've seen a huge change in
the last one hundred hundred and fifty
years from reading the society that was
concerned with production of goods
particularly say starting at food and
then manufacturing other physical goods
so being one that's about organizing
information yet the way that we you
choose to make use of that the way that
we fund the use of that is through
selling us things and I think that we
need to somehow go well beyond the
discussions about universal basic income
and start to really I think we have an
opportunity right now to even change the
debate from work I mean why shouldn't
work the supreme sure
just in terms of technology scaling down
and cost until everyone has like a
Boston Dynamics dog where everyone has
the newest magically goggle augmented
reality and things like that
III think that we will eventually get to
a point like that and that's gonna be
tremendously impactful especially for
people that are low socioeconomic status
once it's a couple hundred dollars to
afford something like that versus the
tens of hundreds of thousands of dollars
for things like that it's something to
keep in mind and I was will probably end
up having many more discussions like
this across the next couple years is the
the difference in social stratification
and speciation potentially of
socio-economic statuses I do firmly
believe that if we're not having a
global conversation about the potential
split that we're gonna have in terms of
eight people right now own as much
wealth as the bottom four billion people
on the planet that those you just just
remember that it's the people that can
own the artificial intelligences and the
genetic engineering and the colonization
of space are the ones that will just
straight-up do that without the
potential looking back why would I why
would I not want to purchase a third
space station for myself rather than
hire 50 people on earth to solve a so
problem so there's all these
conversations that I love having about
the future that I really want to make
more popular and that actually makes
sense of my answer to your question
which is these days or in the future is
it really going to matter if we've seen
the democratization of technology occur
in something like drones where you know
for three point four billion dollars you
can have an autonomous satellite then it
can go down to you know 300 million
dollars and you can get a Predator drone
then it dropped down and fir you know 1
million dollars you could have something
else and then the ten thousand dollars
you could have a drone that was no
professional-grade
but down to hobbies drones and now
you've got little micro drones that are
under every Christmas tree and sold in
every shopping mall but the thing is
nobody has done anything useful with any
of the drones below a certain level so
what was the point
and many people there is an entire
investment bubble around it where people
went well yes why physical technologies
have scale issues and the things that
have the greatest impact like you talked
about writing it's a technology that had
a network effect in the same way that
many of our communication technologies
have and what people haven't harnessed
yet with say drone technology is having
some sort of network effect capability
whether it's manipulation or an
information one and these things are
still to come so the spread of the
technology is often quite separated from
the real impact of the technology
augmented reality is the future of
Education in two to five years when
every single person is able to afford a
pair of magic leap are going through
reality glasses and they're able to
potentially retrain from the fields that
are being automated in just a couple of
months or even a year or two years you
can potentially become an artist or a
creator of some sort of solving some
major problem rather than doing a
repetitive task I think that that's
gonna be a major equalizer the
technologies like that and then I think
the middle question yeah
thank you yes sir
kind of piggybacking the last question
with the wealthy people and then also
because there's been discussion about
China having a stake in a eyes and other
countries do you see there's a
possibility for like a new space race
against with like who's getting the AI
first who's getting the best robots
first and is it gonna be between
countries I think we're all nodding and
saying it's already happening I thinks
I'm a big time I mean the the what is it
Arnold foundation so there are four or
five competitions in the I the last
twelve months
they are known foundation competition
the imagenet which is the most famous
the cocoa which is Microsoft then four
or five all of them look at the winners
they're all Chinese teams period and and
and it's a it's a national program so as
you can imagine China right now is
investing it's flooding universities
with money and so we can discuss forever
about that who is more creative who is
not more creative but in terms of the
number of engineers that they are
producing they twelve the US and even
before this 2015 I think I look up the
date the data about stem graduates China
is ten times more than the United States
even considering the population is still
a lot it's so more math I mean a I at
the end of the day is computational math
so their graduation a lot more 2016 was
an important year in deep learning but
not because of half ago because it was
the first year that China produced more
papers in AI than the United States so
and you know we can argue why my wife is
Chinese a standing in front of me so I
said I can't
to get into politics Jordan is it it's
been a day I as well you know
interesting things that was predicted to
happen in 2019 it's already happened
China is purchasing and producing more
of the world's robots than any other
country and the only reason it's not
featuring on the most dense robotics
robot Association really like Germany
Japan and Korea and the USA is the per
capita ratio because if you look at the
total they're ahead of everybody now and
that's what you can do but in terms of
say the space race we've seen a
transition from a space race that had to
be the province of governments to being
run that is a private enterprise because
the cost of the technology has decreased
and last year to my great pleasure
because I'm a quasi which is a Kiwi
Aussie in New Zealand started launching
satellites okay
who would ever when I grew up wanting to
be an astronaut never in my wildest
dreams did I think that New Zealand was
going to be launching rockets and now
even Australia's got an agency a Space
Agency and they only just got it this
year just wanna make one contrast I
think to the previous question I think
we danced around definitions of
intelligence and what's artificial
intelligence I think that the crux of
that question is what within means and
you have to define what winning means
while everything that's said about China
and other parts of the globe are true
the space race was different there's a
stark contrast because the objective was
very very clearly articulated to put a
man on the outer orbit who does that
first wins I don't think we know clearly
at least I don't what winning in AI
really means I believe is it publishing
for academic papers or putting more you
know creating more companies so so I
think it's a constant debate China is
doing a lot of really really important
things that that that that feel right
and you need to be putting emphasis on
an adult levels etc but I think it's too
early to declare who has one that brings
but my concerns not so much who's going
to win between china-us unfortunately I
think I already know who is going to win
but I agree with him that's difficult
that depends on you defined with my
concern is all the other countries see
we already live in a world where there's
a huge gap between Silicon Valley and I
don't want to name countries pick a
country in Africa Latin America where
the gap is colossal I mean it used to be
a gap between a country that there's
1000 cars and the country there's only 5
cars but now we have a future reality 3d
printing biotech and so on and so on and
so on if they don't and tomorrow we'll
have how many thousands of deep learning
systems and whatever and they don't so
the gap between those two three
countries which is really us China Japan
Europe Singapore ah but the big ones is
really just three or four and the rest
of the world that's that's a huge gap
where you know a country in Africa can
never catch up so my concern is not so
much who's going to win between the
powers is what happens to 90 percent of
the other countries exactly yep all
right who's had their hand up I think
you've had your hand up quite a while
okay I wanted to direct this at fsor
pierrot I hope I got that pronounced
correctly
I wanted you to one of my great heroes
and it's one of your countrymen the
original inventor artist whatever you
will I think has been you might say done
some artificial intelligence in his day
and that would be the great master
Vinci who put all these things together
and you could go down the inventions
which were political well more than
political they were used in artillery
and so on and so forth which had a
certain amount of artificial
intelligence you might say could you
take his position by the way all of his
was driven by human creativity could you
respond as if it were him as how he
might see this issue today so you want
me to pretend I think I act a lot of
these people started with you all with
Alan Turing would be disappointed that's
always been my feeling I gave a talk at
yourself Alan Turing's
what was it birth 100 anniversary I
remember and in my presentation I would
say Alan Turing would be disappointed
because I think we go we tend to go down
the route of practical things that's
what really happens you know as I said a
I as many failures the failures of AI
are the most interesting things like
Leonardo was bought creative in art and
science oh my god that's so complicated
even even for us humans measured for a
machine so what we tend to build is
practical tools and we are very far from
having anything that is real creativity
the other reason that many of these
great people would be disappointed is as
human beings as we use technology we
tend to lose something about the human
creativity and other simples example is
when you follow the navigator and now
you see people following the their form
the smartphone
inside a shopping mall it has become too
complicated to ask somebody excuse me
where's the store right you just follow
the Machine I don't think that de nada
would be very impressed with the human
beings that we have today with the
technology I some of these inventions
have been implemented so it would just
ask us why did it take you so long new
technology becomes available new forms
of creativity become possible there is a
whole field of sound design which is now
accessible to everybody because we have
things like GarageBand which didn't
exist before
of course it simplifies and perhaps have
been trivialized certain things that
would require a whole band of musicians
before it gives them it takes away yeah
interesting discussion and very broad I
must say but you leave me confused
between automation and artificial
intelligence to me you know your example
of an automatic transmission to me
that's not artificial intelligence I
mean it is it rolling anything about you
know your behavior and at least today I
don't think so
so depends if it's a test or not do they
have a IND it's an electric motor so
there's no transmission so anyhow but
you get my point here so to me there's a
huge difference between automation which
is kind of a pre described process
that's taking place and artificial
intelligence or whatever however you
define it but something that learns that
takes data and runs out of those data
and that Titan does something different
and then here comes to transparency of
course right so you have not helped me
understand that power pedal
the discussion what's clear is that most
artificial intelligence doesn't really
learn and most systems for automation
these days does sense and think so
we have thinking rather than learning
here and we have thinking and sensing
here in automation it is a spectrum and
there's a lot of things that still pass
as robotics that now we they're really
stupid okay but technically they pass
this and let's just leave it at that end
of the spectrum of automation up to
things that are just nowhere near human
capability except in very narrow
specializations whether we're talking
about a robot arm that can move 500
pieces a minute and put them exactly in
the same place every time or whether
we're talking about the calculations
that allowed to successfully play go for
using artificial intelligence but it's
not the learning that we think put that
on a spectrum again there was thinking
there was thinking and sensing and then
there was learning where where a
perception based and then we have
manipulation base and we have what I
would still call calculation based
thinking rather than the whole nuance
spectrum that we have you can elaborate
on this via if you just look at it
historically one of the oldest
approaches to attack were expert systems
which had no learning whatsoever all it
did was put a process into a computer
and it let it do it perhaps faster
perhaps a little bit better but more or
less the same where the human would have
been able to do fundamentally but
nowadays AI and machine learning are
becoming synonymous because of the way
industry is viewing it AI is a lot more
broad than machine learning and so we
can have AI without having learning
without having data because we had a guy
for decades before hand that being said
I agree with you actually that the
boundary between computer science in
general and a
specifically is a little bit blurred I
just want to add one more dimension
actually the way I think about this is
since paying for computer act and create
either design we could call it that as
well and the more you have combination
of those things done by it by an agent
the more we can think of it as more
intelligent so there's always going to
be different combinations of those kinds
of capabilities in assistance of the
future but I think the hard thing has to
bring it all together in an integrated
fashion and and the more that is if
you're on this side of the spectrum as
opposed to sort of pure automation side
of the spectrum because I tell me I'm
doing artificial intelligence and I keep
asking questions until I figure out
there just uses statistics so we've
known for yeah awesome
all right Tolga do you want to close out
by speaking about Park for a little bit
sure sure well I mean I first of all I
just want to thank you I want for
moderating thank you you're great a
great conversation and the dialogue
hopefully everybody enjoyed it just as
much as I did and and my mics our
panelists so I just want to thank
everybody for coming and maybe put
another quick note and announcement for
our next event we do this regularly our
next event is gonna be on March 22nd and
our innovation services group would be
speaking about how we explore you know
our approach in exploring technology
before it even exists and I think that's
just going to be another fascinating
night to talk about that interesting
topic so again thank you for coming and
hope to see you with us next time thank
you everyone
[Applause]